a reject nation how you doing it's Greg
Alba here so while we were at a
screening of red Sparrow review come
this weekend man the era Stardust one
idea top 10 this news article dropped on
every movie news site about Tarantino's
next movie the one that surrounds a
Sharon Tate incident Tarantino released
the title and a logline
and two of the main stars here two stars
being DiCaprio and Brad Pitt but more on
that in a second this film is gonna be
called once upon a time in Hollywood and
you know he likes his like Sergio Leone
things Once Upon a Time in America the
story that takes place in LA in 1969 at
the height of hippy Hollywood two lead
characters are Rick Dalton DiCaprio
former star of a western TV series in
his longtime stunt double cliff booth
both are struggling to make it in a
Hollywood they don't recognize anymore
but rick has a very famous next door
neighbor Sharon I get what they were
probably going for but now all I hear is
that it might have been because I once
had an idea that was a comedy action
film about an action hero who gets
kidnapped one day and is like stunt
double of 15 years decides to go save
him and become a real that's what comes
into mind here to that plot synopsis I
think it's interesting that this is who
the story is based around because
everyone's talking about it is like the
Charles Manson movie the Sharon Tate
movie but it's like who the hell are
these guys these real people I haven't
even looked that up but these guys real
Rick Dalton I feel like probably
not Rick Dalton actor one credit from
1937 he's real he's a real guy full
names Richard
this is giving Tarantino the chance to
do another historical fiction type of
piece I mean it's not historical in the
sense of like a war movie but this is a
historical event that did happen in the
60s this is still such a sensitive film
though despite how I really read that
long line film itself this is a
sensitive subject controversial subject
supposedly the character of Roman
Polanski supposed to be in this film -
oh boy and I wonder how he's gonna
handle that especially after you know
all that stuff with Tarantino and the
set of Kill Bill and then Howard Stern
interview resurfaced with him pretty
much defending Polanski like I heard the
whole thing and it would did not sound
good on his and I ranted the interviews
from forever ago but it's still like
that is in the sound good I don't really
know turning of a guy who like changed
his mind on that it's bad it's a bad
look of a one-two punch for sure I don't
know where the court of public opinion
stands on Tarantino at this moment yeah
I think we're so fine with it definitely
problematic AF fav will say that because
you know you know Tarantino's gonna be
into some problematic stuff I like his
movies a lot and even I am a little bit
like please handle the Manson's stuff
with poise like I feel like he can I
just III worry the cool part about this
guy's let's not forget it's DiCaprio and
Brad Pitt sorry side by side a Tarantino
movie maybe Tom Cruise don't know what
role he's been approached for it might
have been one of these two roles which
is funny because there's a vision if
possible to thinker isn't Tom Cruise and
Margot Robbie supposedly being quarter
to play sure and tape I mean that would
be freakin stellar but just alone
DiCaprio and Brad Pitt starring side by
side in a Tarantino film that sounds
awesome I feel like they might have done
a movie together DiCaprio and Brad
but there's definitely not a movie words
like they're the stars yeah them too
that alone gets me excited because you
know there's like that era of like Tom
Cruise Brad Pitt DiCaprio you know those
Hollywood white boys yeah it's something
I'm very excited by and DiCaprio hasn't
done a movie since the revenant and so I
think a great way to come back onto the
scene is with a Tarantino film
especially because everyone really felt
he got really gypped for Django
Unchained Man I imagine Brad Pitt being
the stunt double will probably be more
of a funnier type of role I'm just
really curious what Tarantino's approach
is gonna be with this movie man because
it's such a sensitive subject all the
crap that Aaron T has been getting
lately
even though Huma Therme has been like
yeah we're actually really cool now
Diane Kruger was like yeah I said she
seemed at least to be okay with what was
going on and willing to go along with I
would love for him to work with like
Christian Bale - and I mean if you get
DiCaprio pick a Christian Bale and Tom
Cruise has to make his Tarantino retired
from making Tarantino movies and just
decided to make like fun movies I would
I would kill to see his oceans I'm
curious to see what he does with this
hateful a was seem like kind of divisive
9/4 like most people more on the
positive spectrum for that movie
especially critical wise I like it's not
my favorite Tarantino film but I really
like it world war 2 there's a lot more
creative freedom I think you could do
there eat a like Tisha's story within a
world war 2 setting well know it's been
a very specific date with documentary
footage of these people and all that you
know nobody's gonna get overly anal
about you changing history and killing
Hitler they were they probably will be
very upset if you if you men handle such
a grim gruesome and tragic real scenario
that yeah like those people some of
those people are still alive it's a much
more touchy subject yeah I think he's
definitely capable of taking that on my
best hope is you know the part of me
that does love Tarantino movies hopes
that he's just matured enough to tell
this tale guy alright guys well I'm
excited for the pairing and DiCaprio and
Pitt put it in the comment boxes
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification beli get notified
time one of our vids is up and check us
out on patreon full-length music video
and TV show reactions over there
including me do an attack on tight end
the flash recover Black Lightning
together we started covering my hero
academia he's doing Riverdale Runaways
is probably more to come keep a lookout